there's some basketball player you know
me I don't follow Sports very closely
baseball is the only one that I really
follow much at all but there's this
basketball player his name is proverov
and proverov has a religious objection
to putting on the Gay Pride flag on his
jersey and he was told by his team that
he had to wear a gay pride flag Jersey
and he said no I'm Christian that
actually contradicts my faith so no
thanks I'm not going to wear I'm not
going to wear the jersey and they said
you have to wear the Jersey he said I
want to wear the jersey and it was like
that scene in Seinfeld when during AIDS
everyone wanted you to wear a little
ribbon on your clothing and Kramer said
I want to wear the ribs wear the ribbon
why aren't you wearing the ribbon and it
has reached such a fever pitch that some
Looney Tune anchor just went on an
unhinged rant
about this man not wanting to wear a gay
symbol on his body
the theme is not hockey is for everyone
dot dot dot unless you don't believe in
gay rights then do whatever you want
if the National Hockey League's going to
do this if any league is going to do
this do it properly
or reevaluate what you're doing
because there's not a lot of
repercussions and I'm seeing
from any League now it could change with
the NHL
could change with the NHL I think you
find the Flyers a million dollars for
this I'm not kidding
figure this out and stop offending
people on nights where it's not about
that it's supposed to be about
inclusivity
the National Hockey League need to
attack this and figure this out
because what I heard last night was
offensive
and didn't make any sense because for
instance if that was a military night
okay right if anyone in Canada or in the
States on a military appreciation night
wouldn't wear a jersey pregame do you
have any idea the Uproar that would have
happened on that do you have any idea
the backlash do you have any idea what
happened on social media
it's it's ridiculous do you have any
idea I I'm uh I'm laughing for a couple
of reasons one is I just proved my
thesis that I don't know anything about
sports because I thought it was a
basketball player but it's a hockey
player okay all right actually I prefer
hockey to basketball there's more fights
it's a little bit more exciting manly
sport isn't it and in this manly sport
this Christian guy says I don't want to
wear the gay thing please don't make me
wear the gay thing and then this Looney
Tune on the NHL channel he says could
you imagine if if a player didn't want
to wear a jersey honoring military
veterans
foreign
as if to say that a man who goes out
there and fights for his country risks
his life to go kill the bad guys and
protect our freedom and our Traditions
that that is the same thing as a guy who
really really likes doing weird sex
stuff that both of those things are
equally deserving of our admiration well
Colonel I I really appreciate the
sacrifice you made being wounded
overseas to protect my country and you
Julio I'm glad that you went to the bath
house yesterday and that I find both of
those things so terribly honorable give
me both of your jerseys I'm gonna uh no
no one of those things is admirable one
of those things is at best kind of weird
and
a matter that we don't need to talk
about all that much publicly that's the
best case scenario okay how can you
imagine the guy he seems genuinely
confused and he goes on
nothing scares me more than any human
being who says I'm not doing this
because of my religious beliefs because
when you looked at people's lives you
normally say that publicly you throw up
at what you saw
you would throw up at what you saw
and I have seen that a million times in
a lot of different ways so don't don't
give me that with respect don't give me
that because no one's perfect all right
don't tell me don't don't feed me the
religious beliefs line and all of a
sudden the NHL is going to back off this
the National Hockey League today
needs to find that organization a
million dollars and reevaluate how they
support gay rights because because that
is insulting that is the number one
trending topic in Canada that is
insulting what happened in Philadelphia
you remember when the argument was hey
what's it matter to you
hey man what's your hang up why do you
care what people do in their bedrooms it
doesn't affect your life
but if you don't wear the gay t-shirt
we're gonna find you a million dollars
but it doesn't affect you
hey come on how does how does my gay
marriage affect your real marriage it
doesn't but give me a million dollars if
you ever so much as as even cast a
slight glance of aspersion on the
Glorious wonderful thing we call
homosexual sexual behavior
how dare you that would be like
insulting a military veteran
you see how that and do you remember at
the time
when the libs said all that the
conservatives said no man it's actually
a slippery slope and we're not all just
free-floating atoms so things that
affect anyone and certainly groups of
people end up affecting all of society
and they say shut up bigot shut up with
your stupid religion
and wear the T-shirt of My Religion get
your religion out of public where my
religion we're my flag we're my symbols
except my moral order my immoral order
frankly was what the left is pushing
and what he used one of the shallowest
arguments you'll ever hear he said I'm
sick and tired of people invoking their
religion especially these Christians
that's what he was insinuating he didn't
he's calling out a Christian in
particular he said these religious
people generally do you know these some
of these Christians they could sin did
you know that they commit sins yeah so
you better not have any standard of
righter and wrong good and bad you
better not try to do good and avoid evil
because you're a fallen creature and you
sin so therefore you're a hypocrite
having a standard and falling short of
that standard is not hypocrisy we use
the word hypocrisy today in a way that
is very very silly
having a standard and falling short of
that standard as you sincerely try to
uphold that standard is called being
human and pursuing virtue and it is
Central to the Christian Life it is the
the premise of Christianity that mankind
has fallen we can't save ourselves we
are in need of a savior we require God's
grace if we are to have salvation that's
it and this man this obvious religious
Billet bigot rather is is demonstrating
his ignorance and his intolerance and
his all the things that he accuses us of
so maybe the next time that there is a
cultural issue that comes up and those
crazy right-wing probably religious
fanatical types
try to draw draw a line in the sand and
say hey this is not good this is going
to affect society
maybe don't throw the nonsense back at
them and say oh how does this affect you
if politics affects all of us that's why
it's politics
that's what politics means politics
means public
[Music]